good afternoon everyone
[Music]
ladies in macmillan center and it's a
pleasure to have you here with us today
i'm going to be speaking with jean
Rodriguez who is a member of the
European Union legal service and he's
attached to the European Parliament
these are very interesting days for
Europe and the EU today we're talking
about food regulation in the US and the
EU and some of you may have seen our
wonderful poster that we've put around
the campus and I'm tempted to start with
the subtitle of that poster a food
regulation in the EU in the US the
subtitle is does politics Trump science
so Joe why don't you tell us whether in
fact politics Trump's science either in
Europe or the US or both
thank you David well it's true that the
title it's I would say I've seen it used
in other instances so it's not something
completely new but it encapsulate quite
likely the the idea and the discussion
that is always been it around when we're
talking about risk regulation about food
about health and the role of science and
the role of politicians because
ultimately it's for politicians to take
the decision and to make the policy
choices but they should be based on
science and the question is what is the
role of science and how far can science
go in giving the politicians material
the conclusions the results that will be
the basis the foundation for the for
well informed decisions by the by the
policy makers
and I would say that in these kind of
areas where it's very innovative where
there is some technology progress where
there is a lot of debate also about this
modern types of food that it is even
more important to give science a bigger
role and I would even say more weight to
the to the debate but the question is
that as I said ultimately if for the
politicians to take a decision and they
do not always follow science and they
sometimes decide exactly the opposite
direction I think it was also very
interesting to to come up with this
topic not only because I've been working
this with these issues for the little
past six years in the in the European
Parliament as a legal adviser but it's
also because I think here in the u.s.
today we are living very interesting
times to say the least in terms of the
role of science and how science can be
informative in in terms of giving very
important tools to politicians and also
to know how far politicians today want
to to take account of science or in some
cases deliberately go against science
for reasons that are not totally clear
for us as let's say experts in different
areas being political science in legal
science so I think it's a very topical
issue and very interesting to to debate
we come from a weakened whether was
March in science in Washington DC and in
very various others other locations in
the US and around the world and I think
that scientists today are very concerned
about their role in society and how
their contribution is in a time where
politicians not all
not always are very happy about this
this type of contribution I must say
that's one of the most interesting
things or most min of most useful takes
I can I could get from my experience as
a legal adviser is that when you have a
politician coming to you and saying it
is legal or not and I'll say well yes
you can go this way there is no legal
issue and sometimes they tend to want us
they steer the discussion in a certain
direction so that we kind of approve
their policy options their political
ideas and that's not always our roller I
would say it's not our role our role is
to to give a scientific advice and
expert advice and then with the the the
decision-making power to the politicians
that's why they were elected and that's
their role so I think it's going back to
the beginning I think it's a title that
is very interesting and it shows how
important science is today more than
ever because when it's under attack it's
even more important to discuss these
issues and food safety and food
legislation is one of these areas where
you can find many examples of sometimes
politics trumping excitement we're
familiar in this country with the Food
and Drug Administration the FDA could
you tell us something about how food
regulation operates in the EU which is a
very complicated political system with
member states of course and the
supranational institutions of the EU do
you have something analogous to the FDA
at the European level or do you rely on
national administrators and scientists
to bring information forward to the
European offices and officials so yes we
do have
some agencies and for us what we call
agencies are advisory bodies it is not
agencies in the sense of a ministry as a
government department which is the u.s.
meaning of the word for us what we call
the regulatory agencies our advisory
bodies that's giving scientific advice
into European Commission to the Council
of Ministers to the European Parliament
in this specific area of food safety we
have the European Food Safety Authority
ester which is based in Parma in Italy
and they have more or less the same
competences as the Food and Drug
Administration in the US with the
difference that their role is purely
advisory and they have well certainly
they have fewer staffers than than the
Food and Drug Administration also
because their remit the remit of the FS
are of the European food insecure
Authority it's only about food safety
whereas FDA deals also with drugs with
medicines and we also have a different
advisory body a different agency they
use for that the European Medicines
Agency so to explain the bit in general
terms how the decision-making procedure
goes in the EU if you have a piece of
legislation or let's say a proposal a
bill that is presented by the European
Commission and the European Commission
is the institution that has the power
the unique the sole the exclusive power
to initiate legislation then when the
European Commission comes up with that
proposal it has already done some
studies some expertise with internally
beats in consultation with stakeholders
receiving different contributions for
from the public and also internally as I
said through the the regulatory scrutiny
board which it's an advisory body within
the Commission that looks at the way the
impact assessment
done and then the European Commission
presents the draft proposal a bill and
then sends it to the legislators the
European Parliament and the council the
stories of reference I will call it
Council of Ministers to make note to
make it easier it's for you to
understand and in most of the cases
concerning they'll say 95% of the cases
concerning food safety both legislators
the European Parliament and the Council
of Ministers has to decide together in
what we call the co-decision procedure
for today rebranded as ordinary
legislative procedure so look it as
Council of Ministers and the European
Parliament as House of Representatives
and the Senate with the input as regards
advisory opinions from the European Food
Safety Authority so I would say that the
role of the FDA in the United States
it's stronger than the role of the
European Food Safety Authority but that
is also due to the fact that the
political setup is different in the EU
and in the u.s. also because the FDA has
a long history and it's an older
department than the European Food Safety
Authority which is a younger body test
on this 2002 so you can see it's a
rather recent in terms of scientific
input in this area of food safety now is
is EPSA receiving scientific information
from member states and their research
bodies and organizations PETA as well it
does they they work through working
groups on different aspects and in this
different working groups of panels they
have experts from the various skills of
baking
pesticides with additives or
biotechnology and they count on this
expert which are even an expert that
comes for this for this meeting find a
paper and confident declaration of
confidentiality and let's say they are
not employed as such as officials of
EPSA they are experts from various EU
Member States with professors from from
different universities so let's say that
it's a very varied group of experts that
they that they have so it's not only
in-house experts I would say that they
are very those are them very few ones
and they count on the expertise from the
different member states but it does not
mean that the experts when they go to
these panels but they were they are
representing the the Member State the
country from where they come from they
they are there with all their
independence as experts and they provide
their their advice there is also another
rule for the for the for the experts
where there it's very important the
relation between the expert and the
nationality of the expert and that's at
a later stage so what we call the
implementation of secondary legislation
where you have different committees of
experts from the Member State but that's
a different area so for episode 4 the
scientific advice the experts are
independent there has been some
criticism about their level of
Independence but rather because they say
some of them are too much linked to the
industry to biotechnology companies and
not so much criticism that they are
fighting for their own countries of
origin but because they have links with
with with industry that's very common
criticism that SR has tried to to rebut
and in the case is that when
really saw that there was a conflict of
interest because if you had an expert
that has not disclosed he's or her
relation with a certain company than
they are immediately excluded from the
panels but as I said they have absolute
counts on the the expertise of these
independent experts because they think
that these are the people that in real
life beat in relation with industry
innovation with the universities or in
NGOs that they have the expertise to
give their inputs to the debate so
that's one of the reasons why I didn't
want to have the kind of independent
in-house body of experts but rather
counts on the expertise coming from from
the outside world and I'm curious is
there probably isn't a simple answer to
this but as you look back on recent
cases where does the idea that this
particular food needs to be regulated
originated within the this very complex
multi-tiered
organization called the EU does it come
from the Commission which writes the
bill does it come from s where the
scientists are and the scientific
community does it come from Member
States does it come from the industry
does it come from consumers I mean are
there any generalities about where the
idea that for example chicken
chlorinated chicken for example just to
take one one recent exams we don't like
in Europe which you don't like in Europe
which we love and consume or you have
put on a daily basis where where does
the idea about regulation particular
food come from is there any as you look
back over time is there any particular
locus in that complex set of
institutions that is generally the one
that says here's
something we need regulation for or or
does it come from the science community
the political community the industrial
the consumers well I would say that all
of those play a role but I would say
that advocacy groups public interest
groups NGOs are very strong in making
their case when there is a particular
issue and they are Lobby let's use the
technical word play lobby the European
Commission to come up with a bill with
the proposed legislation to tackle this
this issue to address this issue
there is also cases of reaction to food
scares to food scandals we are the mad
cow disease back in the in the 90s in
Europe but to put it let's say globally
I think that the European Commission is
the one that is the focus the center of
all the complains and all the interests
of these different groups and that has
to decide whether or not to come up with
legislation to address this specific
issues I would say that the way that the
European Commission looks at a problem
it is also linked to how efficient the
response can be through regulation they
have to look at a certain problem a
certain food a certain issue and see
whether you really have to step in to
regulate this area or just leave it for
the for the business operators the
industry to do self regulation
in this area of food in general I would
say that the preference in the EU
especially when we're talking about new
foods something that is technologically
new that is that we don't know it the
tendency quite naturally I would say in
Europe is to regulate so we come and we
decide ok we decide that there should be
some regulation on this why not to kill
innovation which is one of the criticism
that is that is appointed at the EU
bodies but because the area is new
the area is has some risks some risks we
don't even know that they exist so I
think we think European Commission will
say that we should regulate this and of
course they are very receptive very
attentive to the different input from
NGOs from citizen interest groups from
the industry as well and that is also
one thing that is a very common in
Europe which is called the precautionary
principle which has in general the idea
that it is more important in Europe or
it has more application in more fills in
more sector than Europe than it has in
the US which there are there were some
studies where legal scholar said that's
not exactly the case it depends on the
area for GMOs
it is certainly like this but for
instance medical disease it's not
exactly like that because the u.s.
responded more quickly to this to this
to this problem also for car emissions
the US was way
ahead of the EU in terms of regulating
the different cancers that were that
were noxious that were dangerous like it
was the us that discovered the cheating
devices in the in the in the cars made
by a Volkswagen so back to the to what
you asked I would say that the decision
is made by the European Commission and
informed in general by what we call the
precautionary principle which is one of
the main principles in environmental law
in food law in everything that has to do
with risk regulation I would say and
it's also in the treaty it's written in
the treaty on the functioning of the
European Union so we can consider it
already a general principle on food law
and a general principle of environmental
law could you tell us exactly what
precautionary principle means we it's
something that Europeans celebrate I
think as as principle and and I think if
the person in the street hears it it
means you have to be cautious you have
to take full account of possible risk
but what does that actually mean in
practice compared with the situation in
the US would you say does this mean that
there is a lower bar before the
scientist scientific community gets into
the question of assessing possible risk
is it something that is applied
throughout the whole process
even up to and including the
parliamentary process and the council
when a bill is being considered how is
that actually implemented I mean I know
what it I know what we hear the words
precautionary principle but I think for
a lot of Americans it's it's a word that
we don't quite know what it means
in an actual practice and and I wonder
in particular there are instances you
can think of where Europe exercising the
precautionary principle has regulated a
particular food whereas the u.s. not
exercising that principle has not
regulated in other words does it
actually make a difference in that the
EU will regulate some foods that the US
will let go into the marketplace well in
in general terms precautionary principle
means that when there is a certain
uncertainty about a specific risk but
you don't have all the data you don't
have all the scientific certainty that
this is a risk that can cause damage
nevertheless you're allowed to take
preventive measures to address that risk
which means that it's a kind of a waiver
kind of derogation to the rule that you
should only address something and you
should only restrict or ban something if
you have all the data available and the
idea is that in certain areas where
there is a risk you don't have really to
have a an actual damage to say we step
in we're going to legislate we're going
to regulate we're going probably to
restrict or ultimately to ban this
substance or this food it is a way
especially that's why it is always
linked with health with food with areas
where you you might consider that the
the risk of an imminent or excite a
danger in general and any damage to the
population is way too big to wait for
more data to happen to wait for more
input from the scientific community to
decide whether or not
to restrict or ban something in what the
GMOs is certainly one of the areas where
you started regulating saying no we
don't want this or rather saying but
these are the conditions and then let's
see how in practice how it goes it shows
also I would say an approach that the
the Asia with the precautionary
principle and I know that in the u.s.
many scholars say that it kills
innovation
it is way too relative and not certain
enough to say to use it as a guiding
principle because by degree you can say
well let's use the precautionary
principle and let's do this this and
this so that's one of the other
criticism that is that is addressed but
you can also see that depending on a
specific risk and depending also on a
specific population that you can decide
that we prefer to say let's take a
precautionary approach and restrict the
use or the authorization of this food or
of this medicine
whereas you would say we in the u.s. we
think that we don't see that problem as
such maybe because we don't see the
target population as as sensitive as as
the one in Europe or also because you
have a different approach to the
scientific results and you say there is
no big scientific opposition or there is
no clear scientific result that says
that this is dangerous therefore we
should not block it and there's this
idea also that you can have one product
that tends to be considered acceptable
in the US and it's not acceptable in the
EU and also to very very innovative
products for instance what we call novel
food we have since 1997 a system of
authorization where everything that is
second technological advanced some kind
of advanced oils rapeseed oil even chia
seeds sauce or food that is traditional
in certain countries but it was not
consumed and eaten in Europe we say well
we have to take a precautionary approach
and the fact that is it is eaten
consumed in some countries in Africa or
in South America does not mean that we
Europe should not look at it and decide
whether or not to authorize and that's
why we also have for what we call novel
foods you can think of insects for
instance now there is a big debate that
we should eat more insects because they
are very reaching proteins and they are
relatively let's say available our very
nature and there it's one of these novel
foods that is authorized in the EU but
there is this scheme of authorization so
to put it simply it's true that there is
a different of culture a different way
of looking at the risk also a different
way of looking at the the scientific
results or the scientific insurgency
because we all know we are more into
social sciences but there is no such
thing as a hundred percent sure thing
that is completely innocuous no
substance no food no medicine is a
hundred percent innocuous otherwise it
wouldn't be that they affected for a
certain mover for a for a certain
property so these are differences that
ultimately leads to a different approach
to regulation and different cases where
something might be prohibited in Europe
and not prohibited here in the US but
just just one one final remark on that
is that even within Europe even in the
EU you have different ways of looking at
a problem just like in the u.s. you know
different ways I mean insurance Vermont
New York California Connecticut
it's very different the approach most
consumers that they have for instance
concerning GMOs from probably the ones
in Oklahoma or Ione different of
different state Vermont was the first
one saying that we want labeling of
genetically modified foods and then was
the federal there was a federal law
saying well let's do it at the level of
the whole us and not leaving it for the
for the for the state the same thing
within the EU probably knows not so
pronounced but you have printed
cultivation of genetic modified
organisms is restricted to approximately
five countries in the EU Portugal Spain
Romania Czech Republic but most of it is
in Spain that is being cultivated and
then you have a core and majority group
of countries which are very adamant in
completely against GMOs concerning
different ways also on the not on GMOs
but on ways of edited some countries
when a certain additives is going to be
added to the list of authorized
additives in the EU some country sites
why do we have any problems with this
why are we so cautious about this it is
also there is also a lot of plurality of
opinions within the EU not so much as
regards GMOs oh I would say the majority
certainly against GMOs consumers and the
countries reflecting the opinion of
consumers as regards scientists it's not
that clear I I would say but just to
show you also that you have different
ways of looking at the issue also within
this big market which is the EU composed
of some 500 millennion that's very
interesting
I want to ask you about that first of
all who exactly in the EU decides that
this particular food should according to
the precautionary principle be studied
seriously by EPSA before it goes on the
market to what extent is that a decision
that that is can be reached in different
ways to different degrees by different
member states so that some member states
say oh that's fine and will allow GMOs
and or some other cause some food and
other states don't and and also in terms
of the implementation I mean one of the
interesting questions in in our federal
policy is and I'm sure it's true in
Europe on almost any type of policy some
countries implement policy taken at the
EU level more fully than other countries
there's a little bit of slippage that
can occur in terms of in terms of
implementation of policy so that's your
last point is an interesting one because
I can imagine that the producers of
these new foods the innovators want to
get in the market and and so could you
say a bit about whether there is or why
you have this variation at the national
level that some some states apparently
adhere to a precautionary principle
themselves in regard to a particular
food whereas other states don't you
mentioned the case of GMOs and and who
actually decides that well this we have
to take this particular food off the
market in all 28 states and study it and
then we'll decide whether it can be
whether it can be marketed
or does it just not work that simply is
it always a case where some states are
are allowing certain foods and other
states aren't a little Messier
sort of a more American kind of
situation when well first this area is
what eclipsed harmonized which means
that you have the same regime throughout
the 28 till 28 member state of the EU
which means that 1 you have an
authorization especially for GMOs but
also for novel food it's done for the
whole territory of the EU and this is
done like this because there is pieces
of EU legislation that said it's like
this so there is a centralized
authorization system with input from the
Member State and the I would say the
biggest problem is the first to decide
whether or not to authorize because you
know that one you authorize something it
will be free from the market for free
for cultivation and for the EU then some
countries would say well but we don't
want to cultivate this but you know that
when you give the green card when you
give the the ok the authorization then
it will be for who the EU and for
instance for GMOs there was from the
beginning one so-called safeguard clause
which is we was embedded in the
regulation dealing with GMOs saying that
some countries could decide on an
exceptional basis for a temporary period
of time decide not to authorize the
cultivation of certain GMO on their
territory so there was this quick to the
general authorization you would say you
are friends and Monsanto all you want
you to have your to grow your GM corn
and you go for instance to France and
they say no we don't want because
we are making use of this safeguard
cause let me see this so look guys but I
have here these authorization is
reservation is valid for the whole EU
how come that you say that and that was
one of them the major flaws that was
that we came across during the
implementation of the GM legal regime
which was the fact that what would
consider to be an exception which is
safeguard when we talk about safeguards
well it's like last resort when
something goes wrong it basically became
the rule because you had something like
at the energy was 11 states out of 28
making use of that derogation saying we
don't want to authorize growing
cultivation of a certain GM corn or
cotton in our territory which is if you
say well if you're giving the
authorization to a company that it
should be valid for all Member States
and then you have eleven of them saying
no you say well there is a problem and
that's pretty ugly on the face of this
problem that the regime was adapted two
years ago and to give more freedom more
leeway into the countries the member
states to decide we want to restrict or
outright ban the cultivation of these
authorized this authorized a substance
of this authorized product you can say
well isn't it a bit strange that you say
find your business operator
I am the EU Commission that says okay
you have the the authorization to to
grow your wonderful corn throughout the
EU and when you go you say no you go to
a certain country that says no I don't
want that authorization I know it but
there is this little article that says
that I can say no the legislature what
did was to mirror to put it in practice
what was the exception and make it I
wouldn't say the rule would say that the
Member States can invoke can claim
certain factories to say no it's true
it was authorized but we don't want that
and they have to invoke a certain amount
or one of the factors which is a only
list socio-economic regional impact also
planning contamination which is also a
major issue because you might say well I
bought this plot of land in France and
I'm going to grow my my
Kameron corn GM corn and others the best
there is and then next to it imagine you
have an organic farmer and the last
thing he wanted to have you growing your
cabin corn next door to his or her
organic corn because there might be a
case of contamination what happens
though if if say some some countries
some Member States of the EU say no we
want to exercise our right under the
treaty to to opt out of that possibility
our consumers in that country
nevertheless able to buy that commodity
from produced in some other state or is
a regulation on the market side of it
the marketing side of it or and and if
that if there isn't any regulation on
the marketing side then that's just the
case of the producers in that particular
country essentially damaging their
market position these are the
competition from another state inside
the EU yes III should effect on the
beginning that we the the the legal
framework in the EU concerning GMOs is
one for cultivation and the other one
for marketing of food and feed so
cultivation by think it's one I said and
it's very there is only one one type of
on GM product being cultivated which is
a type of corn the Monsanto 8.0 but the
the biggest chunk is the one that you
were mentioning we were alluded to is
the fact that there are some products
and most of it is concerning feed so
food for animals most of the feed that
is consumed by animals by livestock in
Europe comes from GM sources for
instance soybean meals most of it is
important and most of it from come from
countries where GM is huge
Argentina Brazil Canada so let's say
that when we say knew of no no no we
don't eat GM food well we don't eat GM
food but our animals are mad does the
animal and the animal the the product
that comes from the animals meat dairy
etc every site will have the GM
precisely the thing is how can you count
or detect that GM presence in the food
that comes out of the animal and also
another point is that there are labeling
requirements which is something that
here in the US are still working on
because there was there was this piece
of legislation that was signed by
President Obama and now it's still being
implemented and there is a threshold of
0.9 percent which is when there is GM
components above 0.9 percent of the
whole product then you have to label it
GM I've never seen such a product in
Europe
why because probably they know that the
publicly consumers would not buy it also
because there is no need for that
because it would have certainly have to
be a product that is imported and
probably more expensive so there is not
really a market for that kind of product
that is to say that it has to be labeled
so when you're saying well I want to
sell my product
the thing is this specific regime that
was more or less put in a very easier
way for the Member States to say we want
to restrict or want to ban the
cultivation this regime of making it
easier the European Commission wanted to
reflect it for the products for the food
and feed they wanted to make it easier
to make use of this of this cause of
these factors for it would be easier for
for many states to say no we don't want
this product but the thing is first the
proposal came from the Commission but
was blocked in European Parliament which
was the first one to receive one of the
first collected latest thought who
receives that so that proposal that bill
from the Commission and the idea was
saying no we don't want this also
because it was sometimes a bit difficult
to understand how could you invoke these
various grounds socio-economic factors
Town Planning contamination
how would it in practice be applied how
imagine New France could say I don't
want to sell this GM product because of
this isn't this also because there was a
lot of of controversy and pushback from
the side of the industry claiming that
the World Trade Organization rules were
being infringed and saying that if you
go ahead with this we will attack you in
Geneva in the WTO so finally I would say
the more lenient regime that is in force
for the cultivation was not mirrored for
the for the food products and therefore
the feed product but you do have a point
in saying that well I'm a producer you
are still using these safeguard clauses
which also exists for the year for the
for the food and feed product you're
making use of it and basically I want to
sell my product and
you keep on saying though we don't want
it we don't want it let's say that as I
said previously that feed is very much a
GM in the EU through import of
specifically soy especially specially
soybeans so that's not a big major issue
because that's basically the the the
most common and cheaper products that
are available on the EU market are GM
feed imported so you as a producer or as
an importer of these GM feeds for
instance from the US or from Canada from
Brazil you would still have a good
market because you know that cattle has
to eat this this this this kind of
products to have protein so let's say
that you still have a good market for
your product as for food for humans not
really but also that was printing the
big biotech companies like Monsanto
pioneer Dubrow Dow Chemicals but the
Monsanto for instance say they were at
the time growing a potato with called a
and flour potato and then they decided
not to run to to file for the renovation
of the authorization because the
authorization for these products is
given for ten years and then the the
company has to apply for the renewal of
this authorization and Monsanto says no
why because the economical terms didn't
make any sense with all these difficult
difficulties that were being that were
being leveled by the by the different
countries for them to cultivate so I
would say if you are a producer of
soybeans in the US you still have
a very good market in the in the EU for
your for your products notwithstanding
all these specific cities of the of the
legal regime for food you you mentioned
something that reminds me of the
subtitle of this talk which does
politics from science you mentioned that
the the Commission came up with a bill
and the Parliament said no and I'm
curious if if that if that is a general
pattern if the Parliament is a place
where the producers say if a producer is
turned down initially by the Commission
after EPS has studied is and said no
while we we're a little worried about
this and exercising precautionary
principle we're not going to let this go
on the market right now and the
Commission then proposes legislation to
that effect it goes to the Parliament
and the Parliament turns it down
is this why does the Parliament not I
guess my general question is why doesn't
the ryr are there instances where the
Parliament actually decides in a way on
this complex on this kind of very
complex scientifically based issue why
the Parliament doesn't take the advice
of the Commission and decides to do
something else it might either authorize
a food that the Commission doesn't think
should be authorized a say a new food
product because of the precautionary
principle or vice-versa so to say you
work and you work in the legal service
so I in the Parliament and I assume you
get this kind of question from
members of the European Parliament all
the time saying why can't why can't we
do this why can't we do that and your
job is to probably say no the most most
of the time to people and say well the
law is complicated yeah one of the
things they hate the most is the fact
that for the actual authorization of
many of these products the Parliament
does not have a say or does not have the
power to block because it's pretty much
done between the European Commission and
the Council of Ministers because one
thing is the Leddy's legislation let's
say statutes right and then you have
what you would call in the u.s.
rulemaking what we would call in the you
jargon implementing acts so let's say
second level one and those ones are
connected by the European Commission so
the European Commission is at beginning
of the process by originating the bills
and then comes at the implementation
level also to authorize or to make a
proposal for authorization of certain
products now the complicated EU legal
frameworks take it's true it's
complicated that's why it's good as they
say it's good for lawyers let's job many
jobs who have further it so the
complicated thing is at implementation
level ready for the authorization it is
the commission that has to decide to
authorize or not and then to do this it
consults a panel of experts of the
Member States and the European
Parliament does not have a power to say
yes or no so the European Parliament is
not is at the same level as the the
Council of Ministers at the F of the
experts of the Member States the
European Parliament can just adopt a
political resolution saying that it's
very much against the authorization of
the proposed GMO of this proposed
substance but in this specific case does
not have the power to look to to block
so let's say that in this area food
safety
normally the the biggest power
for the European Parliament and for the
members of the European Parliament is
when legislation is being drafted so
when you are adopting real legislation
and lobbying statutes
adopting laws which arising the EU
because regulations are directed so
because then they are being lobbied
heavily really heavily by the different
stakeholders and it's there that when
you are asking well but why don't they
follow the advice of the European
Commission the European Commission has a
very difficult task which is to take the
input from scientists also take the
input from industry and you have also
internally battles within the Commission
whether or not to regulate something
whether or not to propose the
authorization or the certain substance
or a certain product it's not let's say
disclosing top secret start saying that
DG director generals of the Department
of Environment and the department's on
industry sometimes do clash because the
director-general for industry in the
European Commission looks more at the
market at the economic operators VG
environments who of as well very
intention well-intentioned people have a
different sensitivity so they are
probably more precautionary principal
oriented so sometimes what you have from
the final bill that comes out of the
European Commission before being sent to
the legislators is a compromise it's a
compromise and most of the times of the
Commission acknowledges that it's a
compromise that there were attentions
and they say okay now it's for you
European Parliament and for you council
of ministers to sort things out during
your role as Co legislators we did our
work we did our consultation of
stakeholders we come up with a proposal
of legislation now you are the one
they're going to rubber stamp it they're
going to amend that are going to
to propose things you are the
legislators and sometimes we do you do
see proposals that are not very I would
say demanding or let's say they are
intentionally low-key I would colleague
like that because they know that
sometimes it's it's impossible to to go
a bit further than that during the the
normal decision-making process because
there will be a lot of debate in other
instances you say the Commission starts
here with a very demanding one knowing
that it will be watered down through the
legislative process by the council of
ministers and the European Parliament
but just the main take for this is there
is always always a lot of lobbying from
the different actors from the industry
from advocacy groups from the very first
moment one commission asks for input
from the stakeholders until the moment
that the council department are
discussing the piece of legislation the
bill and are going to adopt it and that
is something that it is very unique in
the at the EU level it's not very common
or was not that common at the the level
of the Member State I would say that in
some Member State Exam I'm a lobbyist if
you say that in Washington DC that's
fine it can even be very prestigious the
a friend of mine said when when she went
back to her family so I got a job as a
lobbyist they looked at her and said
what why I mean do you need some money
or what what's wrong with you because it
has a very bad connotation in some
countries at the EU level in Brussels is
very normal just like it is in DC but
this to show that the most important
thing is for you to say I'm representing
these client this industry this NGO and
that's fine from the moment you know who
you are representing that that's okay
and then it's for again
politicians to decide whether or not to
accept your points and to put it in
practice in in in legislation through
amendments that they submit I want to
ask you one last question and then open
it up for questions from the audience
but after talking about this what would
you say in it I know you're very
cautious person and you very
diplomatically sensitive and so forth
but how would you answer your question
does politics Trump's science when we
get to the European Parliament in
particular in dealing with this but and
I don't know if you want to make a
comparative judgment compared with the
EU and the US but what what do you think
it it does the Parliament itself have
the scientific capacity and the capacity
to be impartial and weigh all of this or
does it end up being the interests the
stakeholders with the loudest voice that
in the end when in the legislative
battle well the thing is the parliaments
in seven or eight different political
groups now and basically they cater for
all different kinds of approaches and
you you do see a lot of opinions but
what I can tell you from my experience
is that in some cases and in cases of
food safety I say in general you have
clearly two maximum three positions
there is sometimes a like left-right
split there are sometimes a north/south
split that's the Parliament mirrors the
debates in society so it is something
that it's one of the major seats out
the Parliament is that it's very public
it's very open and you know the opinions
of different political groups and of the
different members of the European
Parliament notwithstanding it's like
that
during the informal informal
negotiations proper piece of legislation
there are some criticism saying that
well you should be more open and saying
these are show with the documents you're
working on shows the the the different
trust that you're working on beaten
please don't be so secretive about what
you're about the text words that you're
working on but I would say that there is
a quite open and more open approach in
the European Parliament
thanks to this variety of politicians
you know that some are very open and
tend to suit immediately available
online
sometimes confidential documents it has
happened because they are inside our
primitive rhythm of information so if
one one of the the things that I am that
I've seen over the years is the fact
that even if there is a kind of a cloak
of secrecy in some of the decisions
ultimately you always find the documents
and you always find the the the the
origins of the discussion why because
you are dealing with very different
people with very different politicians
it's not Democrats and Republicans it's
the center right the center left the
Greens the Liberals and what is very
interesting is when you see the doesn't
the frontiers between the different
political groups blending and becoming
almost non-existent for certain issues
that they consider very important and
for instance for GMOs sometimes you see
well they should be right but thinking
that they would be more business
oriented but they are very Pro consumer
in the
aspect for instance a certain political
group so I would say that the the thanks
to this breach meant complex group of
political actors you do you do find a
way and you do find a variety of
opinions being debated within within the
the European Parliament and that is
something that you find a bit less in
the Council of Ministers which is more
national identity or which one the
national interests of each country's or
sometimes of countries in European
Parliament it's more cross I would say
it cuts across countries and you you
find a lot of interest sharing among
politicians enemies of different of
different countries because they
consider that their role is to defend
the European citizen and not only the
citizen of the country from where they
they come from because it is a directly
elected body and it's they are there but
they are not only representing their own
constituents which are okay they are
primary they're the primary like
customers but they are also represented
by voting yes or no representing the
whole of the of the European Union and
the whole citizens so I would say it's
very rich complex yes that'll be but
that's why it is so interesting and I'm
being very very frank about it and not
being diplomatic when I mean when I say
this it is sometimes very complicated
and challenging but it's 28 member
states we're not talking about 50 US
states which are lately but which you do
share some more things than 28 countries
with 24 different official languages you
do have to acknowledge that it's way
more complicated to find a common a
common thread among them that too
common thread among 50 US state
certainly is well thank you very much
I'd like to open it up now we have some
time for some questions so yes please
and then my part of my question is to
what extent that change and drafting the
legislation
well about trade agreements certainly
when the Commission comes up with a
proposal with the bill it's one of the
most important elements to take into
account it's the fact that if you have a
trade agreement and if you have the
rules of the World Trade Organization
you do have to comply with with those
with those rules so you you can't be too
flexible in what you want to do if there
are some rules that say for instance
that you cannot discriminate against a
different country for that for instance
if you want to to invoke some
socio-economic grounds you really have
to be very specific about what you want
because otherwise you've run counter to
those to those rules so definitely at
the point of making the the proposal the
bill European Commission does take into
account the trade agreements and more
generally the World Trade Organization
rules then throughout the the the
process when we in the Parliament and in
the Council of Ministers we start
debating the the file the dossier we do
also have to take into account those
rules and it's one of the things that we
receive some input sometimes from from
third countries saying for instance when
I I worked in the biofuels directive and
I remember that one of the one of the
things that we that we had to deal with
was the fact that there was a certain
rule that was considered by Indonesia
and Malaysia discriminatory because they
say the way that you're dropping it kind
of is aimed at us as producers of palm
oil because it was about deforestation
it was about how to encounter a certain
a certain to give a certain factor to to
biofuels made of that kind of timber so
in both preparation of the legislation
of the bill but also during the the
process in the Parliament in the Council
of Ministers you do have to take into
account those those rules and especially
third countries all the countries they
are very aware of the debate they have
their embassies in Brussels
checking very carefully legislation that
is being debated because they know that
it might conflict with their interests
and sometimes they find that there might
be problems with WTO rules that in some
instances might be in favor of those of
those countries so they just wave a flag
and say be careful here there might be
there might be a problem just to say
that yes it is the trade rules are
definitely something that we have to
take into account both the European
Commission when it starts the the work
to prepare the draft but also the
Department in Council when we are
working on the on the and substantial
piece of legislation I hope I've
answered your question but I can really
you can follow up on that
further question is what happened
regulation in our country
is you
what trait yep
trade agreement is one of the exclusive
competence of the EU which means that
and that's one of the debate activities
is one of the experts very well very
much aware of concerning brags it is the
fact that all trade agreements are done
by the EU as such and not by the
individual country by the individual
member state which means that the rules
it would be the rules of the EU trade
agreement between the EU and Mexico
Japan whatever and then when you have
ear regulations the e regulations are
directly applicable in all Member States
just as if they were normal internal
national legislation they are on the
same level as national legislation which
means that you would have trade
agreements which is EU law but national
law as well because they have the same
force and are valid in the Member State
as such and you have EU regulations
which are also applicable as such in the
Member States so both of them you would
have the same force in a national
country in the international members say
both of them would be of the same level
and both of them would be valid in the
same way then you have directives which
is a different type of instrument which
is EU directives they say you have to
reach these names base targets but it's
for you the National member states to
decide how to get to those targets so
you enact you adopt you passed
national legislation that will conform
to those targets that are in there in
the EU legislation but all of this you
have to see that one of the main
principles of EU law is either the
supremacy the primacy of EU law so it
means that when the countries come into
the EU the
know that they have to accept what we
call the body of law in their legal
systems well that's one of the things
that in the bragdun ago she ations and
the bracket campaigned rather with was
was quite um was that was one of the
other the main problems for the
breakfast here is saying that we didn't
find up to this well they did because
one of the things that when you enter
the EU when you become a member is you
sign up to the rules and if there's one
that says it you have to accept the body
of law what we call the aki and you have
to accept the supremacy of the EU law
then this means that if you have for
instance national laws that are contrary
that infringe that go against what was
decided at a level you have to change
them it's one of the obligations of the
the member states is to conform is to
adapt their own legislation to the to
the obligations undertaken at EU level
and this is something that it's more
problematic when you are a new member
state of the EU because once you're
already inside even if your position was
is not the one that made it to the final
let's say if you're discussing some
piece of legislation and you know that
that will force you to change your
national legislation if that regulation
that will be adopted in Brussels it will
force you to change the national
legislation you know the moment that you
see okay we lost the battle we voted
against but the majority is work in
favor of this rule which means that now
we have to change our national rules so
you are already inside the the community
and you'll you already know that you
have to change national legislation but
and you also have European Commission as
what we call the guardian of the
treaties but which does the role of
checking if the member states are
actually complying with the rules if
they are
modifying repealing their national
legislation that goes against you law
and this is what let's say I have two
tasks for the for the European
Commission but that's the other main
role of the European Commission not only
as initiator of legislation but also as
Guardian as these as I said at the
beginning and at the very end checking
if everything goes well and this is
something is not at all mirrored in the
system of the US and that's why I think
the separation of powers or not does not
exist in the EU legal framework it does
not as we know it no it does not it's
it's very it's very specific you can
call it loss it is easier we can call it
like EU loss just for ease of reference
we go eros
regulation no what you have is since you
have the EU lot and they have supremacy
it means that you have to implement you
have to apply them and then if there are
questions of interpretation then you can
raise the issue in your national courts
and then the national court can send the
question to the European Court of
Justice to say please help us in
interpreting this question that is
linked with a EU law and we need your
cooperation we need your your your
expertise for this so there is what we
call this dialogue of jurisdiction where
you have the national courts which are
the normal courts applying EU law and
that's one of the nice things about
erodes but it's not only the European
Court of Justice in Luxembourg that
applies euro no I mean there is all EU
28 member states courts that actually
are the normal courts applying a law but
if there are questions on the
interpretation if there are questions on
the validity then it is for the European
Court of Justice to to help them to
steer them to guide them through this
judicial dialogue between the between
the court yes
[Music]
did it well
[Music]
so let's be quick question is how did
sort I don't think I did
I'm the person who knows more how we
started well we don't know how it will
end well certainly because they are
there are two big markets the EU in the
US and there is it's in the interest of
both of them to have a trade agreement
because we trade agreements you have
preferential tariffs between the two
parties EU in the US and even more
important than the tariffs so in saying
that we will lower the price for new
cars in the u.s. even more important
that this question of tariffs is the the
regulatory barriers the fact that for
instance that if you want to do to run
to have trade between the EU in the u.s.
you have a lot of regulations that
differ and you do have to check if the
cars comply with the certain standards
and the standards are different so today
in in trade law and in trade agreements
it's not so much as it was before about
lowering the tariffs because overall
they are already generally low it's
about what they call the non-tariff
barriers so these regulatory barriers
the fact that you have different rules
in one in one country or in one block
and different rules in another block and
what was considered was that it was very
much in the interest of the EU in the
u.s. to have this overall trade
agreement that would focus not only on
lowering the tariffs but also on finding
common ground in terms of standards
instead in terms of making it easier for
the traders or in the two countries for
instance for the cars instead of saying
I will have we will have to check every
other site every ship that comes with
cars from from the EU will have to check
all of them to see if they do comply
with our with our rules if you have an
agreement that says that we recognize so
if there is a mutual recognition system
we recognize your rule
as safe as ours then that will
definitely facilitate trade and that was
the idea that was behind the the
international trade agreement then I
mean you know that there was a lot and
there is a lot of debate and specially
uncertain and very specific areas those
definitely fruit is one of them left
side chemicals the idea yes there the
idea sign that we don't want to lower
the threshold of protection in Europe
others saying that well we don't the in
some areas the US says that well we
don't look one to lower our level of
protection because we consider our level
of protection in the u.s. in fact higher
than yours in Europe so they were trying
to make a trade off in India
negotiations now we don't know exactly
while they are sold but they that's what
they say
Wilbur Ross the Secretary of Commerce
seventy interviews Financial Times last
week that it was it's still there but
they're just on pause but apparently
it's not as drastic as TPP the
trans-pacific partnership it means that
apparently the Trump administration does
want to go on with the with the widow
TTIP now
[Music]
yep that true that that that that that
that was one of the em when one of them
the big problems and the criticism and
the in terms of the texts and being as a
hack access to the text or not well the
European Parliament was very adamant and
very strong in criticizing the fact that
the Parliament has to give us the
consent so it has to be that at the end
of the process the Parliament has to say
yes or no we accept this agreement or
not and if there was the the any peas
were very strong in saying look we want
to be kept informed but the the wide
negotiations are going there was also a
case in the European Court of Justice
that said that for trade agreements the
European Parliament has to be fully
informed throughout the the procedure to
inform does not mean taking part in the
negotiations because that would be let's
say over writing the treaties and the
treaties say that there is no role for
the European Parliament is the the
Commission that actually leads the
negotiations on the basis of other
mandates from the Council of Ministers
but something that the European
Commission did was after each round of
negotiations between the u.s. and the EU
team they were they did briefings press
briefings where they said well this is
what we discussed and we we managed to
to get these over this agreement then
precisely because of of all the
criticism they they started
[Music]
disseminating publishing the the text
that they were discussing some of it was
not very detailed some of the group some
of them were more detailed and than than
others but they did put forward those
without those those those texts so there
was precisely because of the backlash
there was really a of the European
Commission to make it more transparent
and accessible I would say as
transparent and as accessible as it can
be in trade negotiations I understand
that when you're negotiating you cannot
be completely open to the other parties
because there should be some trust
between both parties then it's and it's
true that sometimes this you resign look
I understand your position I will have
to talk with my people to see how we can
so the secrecy itself is in the nature
of the Toit agreement but what cannot be
is secrecy throughout the the
negotiation then what you mentioned
about the the tribunal leader for the
investment the so-called is DC so the
investor state dispute settlement King
been a long time since I used this word
so greater that a good that I had with
is yes mine because I enjoyed it and so
this was one of the things things why
should you take out of judicial courts
the litigation that you had between you
two
well I'm not an expert in trade law but
it's true that there are a lot of these
mechanisms in a lot of trade agreements
and it's true that in some of them they
were very how can we put it nicely
diplomatically they were not in the
interests of one of the parties and that
was something that the Commission
accepted took the criticism and they
presented a kind of more nuanced
approach which was creating
another tribunal so it was not exactly a
the same system that they had at the
origin but different I don't know by
heart that the details it was because
the independent court system IDs
something like this whether there was
let's say more of impartiality than in
the previous in the previous dispute
settlement system however they presented
it but it was never actually debated
because then US elections came and so it
is one of the things that the the two
teams of negotiators will have again to
take up if the negotiations to come but
it's true that the fact that you you you
create this extrajudicial body to to
sort out the bait between two countries
in this case I'd say that it's not the
most problematic ones because you're
doing with the EU and the US and this is
the dispute settlement mechanisms they
are very helpful let's say to the in
some trade agreements where you have on
the other side let's say not really
democratic state for saving democracy or
you're not really sure about what you're
entering into when you signed an
agreement or you want to be sure that
there might be something above the
judicial courts of that others say
because you don't trust that those
courts of the other state are
independent impartial so that's why they
came up with this with this with is a
dispute settlement mechanism between two
blocks like the EU in the US I don't
think that there is no say doubts and
reservations about the the way that the
court in the US and the coercing the EU
would would would see and would decide a
certain case so just to say that and I
again I'm not an expert so I'm just
giving you what my input as what I read
and I followed from the from the from
the from the discussions I'd say that
there was apart from the European
Commission it was they really accepted
the like somebody decided that there
should be some some some other way out
but it was not really debated in the
meantime because of the author of the
elections and because I'm not sure when
was the last round of negotiations
probably I think they're in September I
think it was in September so since then
nothing and that's great I hit one
person jewelry answer that very much for
reaching for better way and second
resort to my second question was
regarding the guard called the 40% of
all new booster or no TM foods
yeah just her novel it's a different
point there is no there is also a
safeguard but yes well for both of them
are safeguards courses so well it could
be and well you ever notice these funds
being used either by the government or
by pressuring
the government has protection of the
difficult industry in that common agenda
and how do they bring the pool within
the both discourse of the core
fundamental freedom that's well
protection of health that's the theme
that they say it's the major big
objective is saying our policy aims as a
high level of protection of human health
that's written in treaties and they say
there might be an issue with with
therefore we invoke this clause to
protect human health and environment in
some in some cases in terms of
protectionism I would say that since I
don't see specifically there a lot of
protectionism of or let's say of a
national industry in the sense that if
you because one of the things is that
the EU consumers in general are not in
favor of GM food so I would say even if
you are that we are saying previously
the the famous Cameron corn producer in
difference if if you want if you want to
to try to sell your product and if you
read the Eurobarometer numbers when they
do surveys in saying that 65% say that
no they don't trust you and food you
probably you won't venture and say I'm
not going to spend money with on this on
this
in this market up I think you might
consider that's a bit of protectionism
in general let's say of the whole food
business operators in Europe and not so
much of a national one and I think
that's the thing that I don't see so
much as for instance Italy or Austria
saying that no we don't want GM
cultivation because we want to protect
our farmers or our agribusiness
industries that it's rather just really
going against the fact that we don't
want in general GM food for instance in
what in Spain which is Vedic Lisi it's
the country where most of GM cultivation
takes place also in Portugal my own
native country when they started the
cultivation I mean I must be I must say
that it was very - very recently there
was really no major debate and no major
backlash against against motivation of
GM of GM products I didn't even know
that they were being cultivated what you
have and it's true is the fact on the
one hand you have a definitely arises
awareness in favour of a variety of
products in cider or organic produce so
I would say that the GM there is not
really a market for GM in general in
Europe because people haven't bought
into that they don't see the the let's
say lower prices that would be a major
factor that would be countering the
risky thing of eating GM even if
scientists say that there is no
major problem with that or let's say the
majority of them some of them they say
well yeah but you have to do that the
long-term effect and the long-term
effects you haven't yet checked them
because the time frame isn't there for
that so I I think that it's but looking
at the at the US and one of the things
that the it was one of the criticism of
some of some legal scholars here in the
in the US and saying well non-gmo or gn3
basically has become a way to increase
prices and to create a niche market for
certain products especially in the US
where you say that 75 to 80 percent of a
product some are somehow genetically
modified or one of the ingredients are
genetically modified so you could you
could argue that even in the US and that
for me of course we are talking about
let say north eastern US liberal state
but you go to the supermarket you see
the shelves and see everything non these
non that non-gm all these things so you
you you're almost saying that how come
that the u.s. is so much in favor of
genetically modified organism if
everything now you see a lot of products
labels as such and also the debate about
the the GM labeling also for instance
the fact that the the first animal that
was let some authorized for the GM
salmon or was authorized to go in the
market that would bizarre in 2015 but
the the there was a rider there was a
provision saying that well that it
depends on the enactments and in the
implementation of the labeling on the
rules of labeling of GM products and
since they are not yet being implemented
so it's not really something that you
can know that you can find so I would
say that to wrap up that
politic Trump's science in a certain in
a certain extent it's probably not a
question of trumping science it how far
do I want to take into consideration the
data that is being given to me by the
scientists and that is something that I
can decide how much I want to take of
that data one one other thing that is
really important is to be open about it
and saying that these are the studies
but we want to take this position this
position and this position it does not
have to be a secretive thing like the
Train negotiations it has to be
something that is very clear that there
is a role for politics and there is a
role for science what you cannot have is
some way of trying to instrumentalize
science or create a parallel science to
the very fancy expression but that is
something that cannot be accepted so you
you should be very clear about science
sustaining science the role of science
independent impartial and then a clear
informed political decision and that's
probably the most important thing is not
one thing trumping the other but is one
thing looking at the other and saying I
vote for this I go for this thank you
very much I have my rule
you have your rule and they are well
defined that's an excellent way to bring
this very entertaining and informative
discussion to a close I want to thank
Joe for being here and telling us in a
very interesting comparative way about
food regulation in the E
and and and relative to the US and I
want to also express our appreciation at
the Macmillan Center and the European
studies council for having you here as a
visiting fellow this year it's been an
exceptionally good year for us having
you here and we hope you'll be back and
tear yourself away from the work from
time to time and come back and visit
again in the future but thank you very
much and thank you all of you for being
there this afternoon thank you thank you
very much and it's reciprocal I also
want to thank you very much to you and
to the audience thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]